I'm going to stop this episode with a
question and please don't treat him.
Please don't Google the answer.
What is the country with the biggest
chance of female politicians insight
it's parliaments.
It might be thinking right now,
Norway,
Sweden,
maybe Great Britain.
Well,
if that's the case,
your thinking is wrong because the
answer,
it's actually Rwanda,
one of the poorest places in Subsaharan
Africa.
I'm sure many of you already know this
country,
yet least those of you who are as old as
me,
because in the end of 1994,
the Rwandan genocide,
it appears on every news station around
the world.
It was one of the biggest atrocities in
mankind's history in just 100 days.
There are ones in governments brutally
killed almost a million people.
This meant that every one in five
Rwandans was murdered for decades.
Rwanda.
It was the synonym for humanitarian
catastrophe,
starvation,
and it was a memory of the darkest side
of the human condition.
Nonetheless,
23 years later in the year,
2017,
Rwanda is turning into something much
difference
is from Rwanda investing in one of the
world's fastest growing economies.
Yep.
You heard that rides,
Rwanda is becoming a hot topic in the
financial world,
a country that used to appear on
humanitarian aid commercials.
Now he's starting to fill financial
newspapers and it's President Paul
Kagame has become the new African
rockstar being received a prestigious
places like Harvard or the Brookings
Institution.
Yes,
of course.
Everyone does agree that it style is
kind of areas and winning elections with
over 96 percent of the vote doesn't
exactly sound democratic,
does it?
I mean,
despite all of that,
you can judge a man that he's taking
Rwanda out of poverty.
The figures speak for themselves since
Paul Kagame came into power Rwandans to
triple their income and the percentage
of the population that lives in extreme
poverty is reducing gear.
Now,
the question is,
how did Rwanda end up like this?
Or perhaps maybe this is too good to be
true.
I just the some detail we're missing
here today.
Well,
we are going to answer those questions
before we do.
As usual.
Let's take a look back at the history.
I'm.
Trust me,
this one is pretty intense.
Fabricated hatred.
Remember this date,
April the sixth,
19,
94 on this date,
the plane the Rwandan president was
flying in was hit spine anti aircraft
gun
I
the notes who organized this attack,
but the ones an army soldiers belong to
the Hutu trolley,
blames that rival the Tutsis.
Tutsis were a minority inside ruins.
They're living in an apartheid
situation.
Local media referred to them as
cockroaches,
and many of them had already escaped to
refugee camps in neighboring countries,
but no one could have predicted that the
mounting prejudice would have unleashed
such carnage
bottle.
What messages like this with broadcast
on the radio,
there are one's an army was passing out
clubs and machetes to civilians.
If any of those who to civilians showed
mercy to his or her tootsie neighbors,
he or she would risk being executed as a
collaborator.
Explains why many Rwandans clubs there,
tootsie wives to death,
and 20.
Even some Catholic churches became human
slaughterhouses in just 100 days.
Nearly a million people died by their
neighbors.
Machete.
Well,
now you might be wondering why did the
Hutus hate the Tutsi so much with a
really that different and while the
answer is you expect is,
nope,
you see many African countries have lots
of different cultures and races living
together.
South Africa,
for example,
has nine official languages.
Your guns or it's over $50.
Nonetheless,
Rwanda and territory with surprisingly
homogenous for centuries,
one single language on a single culture,
the Hutus and Tutsis and other tribes,
they lived in relative harmony in the
20th century,
Belgium colonized this country,
one of the first policies made by the
Belgian government was to force the
locals to label themselves according to
the tribe they belonged to.
This way,
it would be easier for the colonizers to
identify who was who,
and during the first years the Tutsis
were the tribe in charge of government
institutions created by the Belgians.
Then one's eight,
those Tutsis started asking for
independent,
and that's when Belgian started
supporting the Hutus with racist
propaganda.
This is how when Rwanda became a
sovereign state in 1962,
Hutus and Tutsis had already become
fierce enemies.
That hatred,
it was fabricated by the colonizers and
many Tutsis had to flee to refugee camps
in neighboring countries.
Among them was the man that you see on
the screen now,
pull Kagomi,
now remember his name,
because it will be the key figure in
this story.
We'll look at Goldman.
He was raised on one of those
aforementioned refugee camps.
This one,
it was situated in Uganda.
It was the beginning of the 19 eighties
back then Uganda.
Ganzer was in the middle of a civil war
and Kagomi along with other Rwandan
refugees for to the Ugandan government
and they want,
and this is how to army as a military.
Legend was born in the 19 nineties.
He would lead other attacks against the
Hutu lead Rwandan government's,
but the turning points was in 1990 for
100 days after that horrific massacre.
On April the sixth,
Tacoma was making his entrance in
Kigali,
the Rwandan carbon with 2,500
soldiers.
The genocide was over and Rwanda,
it had a new government.
This time it was a Tutsi lead.
Governments with Kagomi serving as the
vice presidents,
but hold on just a second because the
story,
it doesn't just end here because imagine
the scenario for one,
he had to help lead a divided country
where genocide survivors how to live
next to the neighbors that had killed
their friends
family.
I didn't tell that Rwanda was one of the
10 poorest countries on earth with few
resources to export,
and on top of all of that,
this brand new tootsie government was
not an example of transparency and
respect for human rights.
As you can imagine,
many of the soldiers who had taken over
Kigali,
they wanted revenge and well during the
next year,
no one made an effort to stop the
executions and the unfair trials.
If this wasn't enough,
many ministers trying to use their
positions to fill their pockets with the
little money that Rwanda hat corruption
certainly on the rise.
Meanwhile for Kagomi had the charisma,
the popular support,
and especially the political ambition to
rise even higher.
And this is why in March of 2000,
let Hootsuite,
president resilience man's without an
election.
Well,
the inevitable happens gamay the eternal
president in the year 2000 army became
the new Rwandan presidents until you
came to Palo with two clear goals.
The first one was to unify the Rwandan
people after the genocide.
The second was to pull this country out
of poverty.
So what did he do to achieve this goal?
Well,
he traveled.
You're going to be created an advisory
team that went to countries like China,
Thailand,
and Singapore.
So can you guess what?
Those three places,
what do they have in common?
Well,
the answer is that they were countries
that used to be poor.
Back then they were emerging nations.
Kagomi arranged meetings with
politicians.
Economists send civil sevens,
and from these meetings he wrote down at
scores of ideas in a notebook.
Then he returns with the golden formula
to build a wealthy country.
This notebook became the foundation for
the brand new Rwandan constitution,
and more importantly,
vision 20 slash 20,
basically vision 20 slash 20 was it
government development plan launched by
Paul Kagame,
gummy with the goal of transforming
wander into a middle income country in
just two days.
Modern,
peaceful country for extreme poverty no
longer existed,
but wait just a minute because this
isn't the normal buzzword filled speech
of a politician Rwanda's vision 20 slash
20.
It had 44.
Clear and accountable goals,
for instance,
except that by the year 20,
21 in every three rooms in this must
have electricity at home for both the
governments and private consultancy
firms.
That analyzing and measuring the
progress of all of these.
Let's take a look as an example.
One of those targets was to make her
one's at a gender equality haven ends.
Now,
the Rwandan constitution requires that
at least 50 percent of all government
positions held by women.
In fact,
at the time of making this video,
there are ones in parliament,
has the biggest share of female mps in
the entire world and to the wage gap
between men and women is lower than in
countries as progressive as Denmark.
Today,
there is a brand new generation of
female Rwandan entrepreneurs leading the
country and what's more Rwanda is
investing the small amounts of money
they collected in taxes pretty wisely in
a country where 80 percent of its
population used to live off subsistence
farming.
The government is built power generators
and roads that increase agricultural
productivity.
Now we're ones in farmers are beginning
to export food to their neighbors.
All of this explains why 23 years after
the genocide,
Rwanda GDP is growing at an average rate
of eight percent a year.
This is similar to emerging economies
like China or Vietnam on the same
streets where in 1994 people were
clubbing each other to death.
Startups like Rwanda motorcycle company
are being born.
The motorcycle factory was created this
year in 2017 with American investment.
If you want to start a company in
neighboring countries,
you will need weeks or even months to
deal with all the paperwork in Rwanda.
You're done with all that in just two
days.
As of course,
this has attracted a lot of foreign
investors,
especially from China and America,
and so now you might be wondering how
did they end up here?
Once Polka gummies secrets welded,
you have the answer.
It has a light side,
but it also has a dark side at gunpoint.
Everyone believes it.
Rwanda works.
Streets are safe and tolerance between
Hutus and Tutsis is imposed vinyl.
No,
no one's in constitution itself forbids
the use of the words Tutsi and Hutus to
refer to a person according to the
government or citizens are Rwandans and
no one should care about their tribe of
origin.
Either the media nor institutions are
allowed to say anything that could spark
hatred or open past scars and well,
in fact,
they call it even criticize the
governance.
Both the police and the military.
They are present all over the country to
make sure that everyone follows these
laws.
Yeah,
it is true.
Balking on me is a popular presidents in
dd has his own youtube channel and to
twitter and facebook account that he
uses almost daily,
but no one else has the freedom to
express their ideas freely.
Well,
the same goes for other political
parties.
We're talking about the president.
He's been in power for 17 years and he
wins elections with outcomes higher than
95 percent of the votes.
As you can imagine,
you is not exactly democratic.
One of his opponents,
friend Kevin,
the only permitted opposition party
hailed the process he had attempted to
run for the 2010 presidential election
party,
was unable to register for the vote.
In other words,
the Rwandan model is based on three
pillars,
ease of investing,
and doing business infrastructure
developments and at the top an
authoritarian governments,
they'd guarantee safety and tolerance at
the expense of other human rights.
Now we want to know what your opinion
is.
Do you think that this lack of democracy
is legitimate?
If the country can step out of poverty
or perhaps Rhonda would be better off if
they structured the country in a more
democratic in Western model?
What?
Please leave your answer in the comments
section below,
and if you do want to learn more about
the history of another African country,
click on this video where I talk about
Angola,
which is the world's most expensive
country.
I've also recently started a new channel
biographics where we look at biographies
from famous people throughout history as
well as the present day.
We've got some politicians on there,
but also business people and other
famous people,
so please do check it out.
There's a link in the description below.
Also say,
please do visit our friends at the
reconsider media podcasts.
You can find them at reconsider media.
Don't come.
They provide the vocals in this video
that are not mine and don't forget we
published brand new videos every Monday
and every Thursday,
so please do subscribe and hit that
thumbs up.
As always,
I'll see you next time and if you want
to learn more about politics and hear
even more of my love before you can join
us at reconsider media,
we have a podcast@reconsideredmedia.com
slash podcast.